good morning my name is alaiko
and i'm developing the market of
precision medicine at
thermofascial scientific in this
presentation
i will highlight our applicable system
and ion tolerant genetic analysis
solutions which
you can use for advancing your research
on software
as you know sas curve 2 has rapidly
spread around the world
we know how important it is to better
understand the associated disease curve
in 19
and our cctv to it as well as identify
suitable therapies and develop a vaccine
thermofacial scientific has a history in
response
in public health crisis we work hard to
make a difference
during not just this of the crisis but
also joining ebola
h1n1 zerskof2 and zika
while today we are talking about our
genetic analysis solutions for saskoff 2
research
thermo fisher has also a hand in
personal protection equipment
in other scientific research tools like
those for protein and serotonin analysis
cryogenic electric microscopy mass
spectrometry
in detection kits and in vaccine
production and clinical trial logistics
our mission at thermo official
scientific is to enable our customers
to make the world healthier cleaner and
safer
it is a very powerful mission and it
really resonates in these days
we are the world leader in serving
science with industry leading scale
and unmatched depth of capabilities
researchers around the world are working
hard to gain a better understanding of
the novel coronavirus with the goal of
rapidly identifying
future treatment options and possible
vaccine targets
we know this research can't wait so with
our comprehensive portfolio genetic
analysis product
thermo facial scientific is your trusted
partner for many applications
as i've discussed today
we have a broad portfolio of platform
in this slide you see an overview of
each technology
at high level our
ion torrent next generation sequencing
system are fast
easy to use platform that offer
end-to-end workflows
id for virus research studies beyond
variable genome sequencing
as i'm going to show you in the next
slide we have two complementary
solutions
the ion studio s5 series is ideal for
labs looking for a cost-efficient
solution for processing large number of
infectious disease research samples
or those doing broader viral research
applications
with the genexius integrated sequencer
you go directly from the nucleic acid to
the report in a single day
with endorph automated workflow ideal
for labs that are new
to in-house engines and want to leverage
the highly automated workflow
including for other clinical research
applications in the future
we also have a full suite of genetic
analyzer for sanger sequencing and
five-part analysis
our newest product the six studio
genetic analyzer
can help you to get your virus research
faster with the system of
in one cartridge including capillaries
polymer and buffer required for the
brand
we also enable harpy the pedomological
studies via
microarray analysis our one portfolio
includes instruments
arrays and free analysis software for
both original genotyping
and world translator analysis finally
we are the leader in real-time pcr with
over 25 years of innovation
we offer sensitive specific detection
and quantification of nucleic acid
target and a suite of analysis software
to power your study
research on the virus our new constitute
7 pro
can help you to improve your biological
studies with smarter workbooks
i'm not going to spend more time on our
instrument portfolio because i want to
show you how you can use them for your
research on sas craft we'll review five
different research areas and showcase
which
of our genetic analysis technology and
solution can help you
we have solution for biosequencing
pathogen detection
epidemiological surveillance vaccine
research and development
and host genetics and population genomic
studies here at thermo fisher we are
committed to serving science in the
battle against after infection
first application sequencing the virus
for example to identify novel various
genomes or
general reference sequences world genome
sequencing offers
important new opportunities for the
discovery and characterization of
microbes
for researchers characterizing their
genomic structures denote the sequencing
and assembly of genome is an important
step
this basic research project required
deep coverage across
the genome and high quality data
scientists at the peter doylet institute
for infection and immunity in melbourne
australia were the first outside of
china to sequence
the at that time named 2019 and co-of
genome
they use the six studio genetic analyzer
to generate the reference sequence
which is fueling global surveillance
research and asset development
we also developed solutions for our ion
torrent semiconductor sequencing
a technology that has revolutionized the
novel sequencing for microbial research
these fast simple sequencing systems
have the highest accuracy of variance in
the market the lowest
substitution rate for single nucleotide
variations
which is incredibly important for
infectious disease research
we have end-to-end solutions allowing to
work with difficult samples and low
input
and still provide really high
sensitivity for optimal limit of
detection
that means directly from low or high
value load
no need for capture we develop a
targeted panel
based on our flagship ion and plastic
technology
the implicit sarskof2 research essay
that enables a streamlined research
workflow for
coronavirus genome sequencing and
epidemiological studies
using a set of id specific universal
coronavirus primer
in combination with a high fidelity
master mix we amplify more than 99
percent of the genome
and sequences on our oriental system to
deliver highly accurate anavaros typing
in under a day you can perform rapid
renewable sequencing
including an ffv as demonstrated by
something by customer
another application of our solution is
the detection of sask2 and the study of
the thiochens in gene expression in
response to pathogenic invasion
we developed the applied bar system
tacman
2019 and cover circuit a singleplex kit
specifically for saskatoon detection
research
one example of research is about
infections
in domestic animals shy and
collaborators
use the quant studio 5 real-time pcr
system to study domestic animals like
cats dogs and also ferrets
they showed that ferrets may be used for
experimental model for sask after
research because their immunological
response is similar to the one
in human
task of 2rna detection can also be
accomplished using fragment analysis by
capillary electrophoresis
in this method we use a cocktail of
fluorescent primers that are specific to
the
nuclear protein and the spike protein
the s
and the r for 1ab sequences in the sask
of 2g
check out our application not for more
information
and anytime you can also confirm qpcr
and ngs virus detection using our single
sequencing platform
and you can also study associated
respiratory pathogen
using our apply by system real-time pcr
solution for the respiratory tract
microbiota
and its 42 verified pathogen targets
the assay is available in different
format and works from different samples
including
nasopharyngeal swaps
obviously our ion torrent sequencing
platform can also be used for detection
of viruses but today
i'm going to give you another example of
how to use them in the field of
epidemiological surveillance
epidemiological surveillance is
conducted to ensure that global
values match the reference trend and
also to monitor for possible mutations
indeed any change in the viral genome
can impact
how the illness spreads in the
population are the treatment
options what are the three perceptions
and
can impact the vaccine development a
very nice example is the waste
water-based epidemiology
remodel and collaborator use ngs not
only to detect but also sequence
the viral genome and perform a
phylogenetic analysis
to indicate the origin of the surface of
two infections in milanese metropolitan
this could help to predict certain waves
of susceptible infection
and cupreser and sangha sequencing can
also be used for such
another example a major challenge for
microbiologists is the prediction of
patterns and
evolution of emergence of diseases
urgent
are any viruses like coronary viruses
typically exhibit a high genetic
variability which caused them to appear
as
cloud of methane coronal virus variants
also emerge through antigenic shift
within animal reservoirs
such as birds and sex using the iron on
basics ask of two research panels
two independent studies in italy found
that cerske of two was mutating at a
relatively low rate
this was positive news for vaccine
research as it indicates that the
effectiveness of a vaccine could be
potentially consistent
possibly over many years but since then
dr fresh from children hospital los
angeles
went deeper in the analysis of cases
using
our pc panel he showed that sask of 2
as it spread in the community undergoes
some mutation within the host and
between individuals
and that these mutations allow for
identification of index cases
community spread and contact racism dr
krish also showed that many of the
mutations result in amino acid changes
that may
lead to antigenic drift with a possible
negative implication
for infectivity pathogenicity pcr
molecular genetic and vaccine
development that's another reason why
more research is required and why our
panel is a perfect
another application of our sequencing
solution is the analysis of transmission
between animals
for example the sequence of viruses in
potential reservoir hosts
led to the discovery of multiple
lineages of pangolin
coronary viruses and their similarity to
saskatoon
suggesting that pongolins could be
considered as potential
in intermediate host and should be
removed from wet markets to prevent
zoologic transmission
we also offer solutions for host
genetics and population genomic studies
this is a search for potential loss
contributors to saskatchewan
sustainability in the hopes of finding
genetic markers for covenanting
progression
and biological insights that might point
to potential broad targets
as you know when a population is
challenged by pathogen
individual responses can vary greatly
depending on their past exposure to
infections
environmental and socioeconomic factors
as well as their genetic background
thus it is important to study how the
disease is impacting the population
how this population is responding it is
important for certification
or when developing a vaccine the axiom
genotyping arrays are low-cost scalable
and fast
technology that can help you to study
the host response for risk and
sustainability
with the works of my design customer
general typing array
you can select from more than eight
hundred thousand geos markers
you have the full clean var more than
nine thousand
ace two where most of the population
arrays are underrepresented
and you can also select broad phenotype
action is a proven technology using
multiple large covalent studies such as
the uk biobank or fingen
collaborators from the uk biobank for
instance show the link between the blood
pressure and phenotype
and the risk for adverse outcomes from
suscribe to infection and
novel genomics genetic determinants of
viral antibody response
so using the exome technology we
developed the new axiom human genotyping
saskofto research array
which includes a lot of benefits of our
modular approach to designing genotyping
guys such as
large u.s grid and multi-thin population
coverage
but more specifically these are includes
three
new module and relevant content for
studying sustainability
severity and immunoresponse results
the first module shown in yellow called
the sask of two susceptibility modules
includes structural variants from viral
entry points and pathways that are
associated with humidity and
inflammation
the second module in red includes
discoveries and
variants associated with chronic
underlying conditions that are
implicated in the severity of the
disease
also including the modules are markers
covering blood groups
and blood phenotypes
they have been implicated in the disease
the third module
in blue includes variants to cover the
regions associated with immune response
for vaccine development and
pharmacogenetics for drug discovery and
development
the system is flexible and allow you to
add your marker of interest
thus showing a superior performance on
newer
key markers the first version
of the axial human genotyping sarcoph2ra
is available
for as few as 96 examples please come to
us with suggestions for the next classes
the racism to develop a vaccine for
saskatchewan
a better understanding of the complex
immune response and how it evolves over
time may help improve decisions around
vaccine efficacy
safety dosage and the duration of the
protection
this slide is quite busy showing the
complexity
and multi-dimensional aspect of the
immune response
sequencing the immune report is a tool
for vaccine development
b and t cell receptor sequencing with
one of our
ngs assets listed here may be used to
quantify human response to vaccination
or infection
here's an example of an experimental
plan using oncoming ighlr
and uncombined tcr blrss to identify
biomarkers using the comparison of human
repertoires between subjects to develop
a mild
or severe infection
understanding the immune response to
surge2 is also important since there
have been descriptions of severe
associated inflammatory conditions for
example kawasaki disease
or toxic shock sample
finally studying the immune response of
surge2
is also key to identify the potential
antigenic drift due to mutation in virus
genome impacting the
spike b cell by pitop that can be
observed in some specific territories
for example the 2343a to g is present in
europe but very rare in china
mutations are not the only factor
impacting the immune response to
zero software the horse microbiome
potentially plays a role in the degree
of severity
in the hospitalization due to
co-infection or even the antibody
response to the virus
this response can vary greatly according
to the gut microbiome profile
so to help you in your research we
developed the ionoplasty microbiome
health research kit
for you to provide the microbial
diversity in your human gut
microbiome research samples we also have
16s metagenomic solution
if you need expression of genes
involving immune response is also a good
research topic
our appliable system client gene
expression microarray will help you to
study
host by voice interaction and immune
response
world transcriptome with cliomd exons
only muscular ios
and the high throughput testing of key
genes and pathways with clarion goes
green
depending on your death and throughput
needs we have a microarray solution to
cover
your studies
for example you can study the the
expression of as2 in
lungs tissue like in these two studies
suggesting that the elevator
expression of ace ii caused by copd
and smoking may help explain why these
cases have much more severe symptoms and
worse outcomes than others
another tool we provide is the applied
system technology
a qpcr panel of 92 genes involving human
immune response
and whenever you want to confirm ngs and
microarray results
you can always use the sangha sequencing
on our apply by system genetic analyzer
and our millions of pre-designed tech
margin expression assets including some
for targets known to have implications
in immune response
before ending i would like to mention
our solution for
cell line authentication vaccine
research is often performed with
cultured cells
obtained from major repository or field
researcher
but an estimated 15 to 20 percent of the
time
cells used in experiments have been
misidentified or cross-contaminated with
another
subline although major repository is now
authenticated cell line identity many
are calling for all researchers to test
an
authenticated sideline identity you can
use our standard genotyping technique
like the str
analyses on our cla identifier plus our
global filer
kits on the 60 geogenetic analysis
finally with approximately 1400
employees globally and over a million
customer interactions annually
our global service and support
organization has adapted to continue
delivering exceptional support of your
research about sales code
our field service team can still make
on-site
visits and installation following all
local and customer travel guidelines
digital conferencing tools are also
helping us to continue educating
customers on how to best use
their instruments to secure your
research wherever it takes place we
are even evaluating with an augmented
reality remote support
i realized 20 minutes are not a lot to
discuss the luxury of solutions
we offer for your research on south
carolina this was just a brief overview
of our broad instrument portfolio
and the many solutions we can offer in
different research areas like
biosequencing
pathogen detection epidemiological
surveillance
vaccine results in development and also
genetics and population genomics
you can learn more at thermofacial.com
coronary virus
i thank you for your attention